in honor of her album guts we are
hosting a gutsy hour everyone in the
audience has taken a very gutsy chance
and many have Olivia to thank for
inspiring them to do so it's weird
because you don't think you're going to
have that kind of impact on someone but
it really does music is so magical like
that so why why guts why that for your
title yeah I just always love the word I
think it has so many interesting
meanings so you know it means bravery um
spilling your guts means like telling
everyone your dirty little secrets which
I feel like is just what I do in my song
y
um amen yeah so it's just a really
powerful word and um I like a
four-letter word you know and me too you
know yeah got to love a four-letter word
every now and then uh so yeah just
became the title I love that I love all
the separate kind of ways you can take
it as well yeah will you tell us about
some lyrics we have we pulled some for
okay because there's so many good ones
um and Lacy Olivia writes and I despise
my jealous eyes and how hard they fell
for you yeah I despise my rotten mind
and how much it worships you I mean
that last
line I despise my rotten mind oh man
just worship I'm like that who has not
felt you have a very poetic way kind of
like Alanis like you have a poetic way
of like wording things but they're so
relatable but it's so poetic wow yeah
where were you what were you thinking
that um yeah I I like hemo that's right
me to me too um I took a poster class
actually at USC this year last year and
I wrote that I wrote a poem called Lacy
for one of the assignments and I really
liked it I'm like I'm turn into a song
so that's sort of where that one came
time to go to college I
know I back that train out I know I just
took one class I was going to the studio
some days and then I'd go to college and
like it was fun it was fun that's so
cool I love that you did that it's
always cool to like progress and grow
yeah yeah always want to stay curious
you got like a great song out of it Dam
all right um so next in all- American
Olivia says I am they like I am light as
a feather I'm as stiff as a board I pay
attention to things that most people
ignore so first of all what do you know
about that game that's a game I played
when I was a kid yeah did yall do that
light USA has any done okay did did it
work well here's the thing there's like
15 of you around the body with your
fingers and you're all doing it at the
same time that's what we did so of
course we're all going to lift them I
mean these are powerful fingers like if
was all of us and we're all like tiny at
the time we were playing it that's true
well my mom used to tell me about doing
that at sleepovers so that's how I knew
the I was always fascinated like that
seems impossible I need some physicist
to like explain it to me I think it's
just literally we we want it to be
magical but really it's all of us just
underneath foring it lifting the person
up we're like how is this
happened yeah but I always thought it
was a a really interesting phrase and so
I've been trying to fit into a song for
a long time so I thought it was an
interesting way to describe like it
seems kind of impossible I as a feather
stiff as a board so I thought it was a
good way to describe kind of the imposs
POS standards that are set for us as
women so it's just kind of yeah I
love I love that you take something that
everybody knows too and you twisted in
his that's very
[Music]
[Applause]
smart thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home